[Applause]
[Music]
we just kicked off October but good news
for the horror fans out there this
episode of new releases does contain the
months first big scary game unless
you're afraid of orcs in which case
we've got to for the rest of you this
episode has a heaping helping of anime
robots and elephants let's talk about
some of this week's biggest releases
starting with Middle Earth shadow of war
the first game took the world by storm
with its orc fighting action and nemesis
system and those have been cranked up to
11 with a sequel this time tallien and
caliber in boar can gather followers
from other races and middle-earth and
use their own troops to build strategies
against Sauron and his army and while
combat was largely about gaining powers
and hacking your enemies to bits before
the sequel gives you way more options
for exploring or fighting shadow of war
comes to ps4 Xbox one and PC on Tuesday
October 10th but if you just can't wait
a few more days we've got plenty of side
missions and combat for you to check out
on GameSpot let's move from fantasy
worlds to alternate dimensions a cyber
dimension if you will cyber dimension
Neptunia four goddesses online sends
well four goddesses into a virtual beta
where they're tasked with saving the
world from an evil demon king what this
means for you is a hack and slash RPG
with tons of skills to learn and
dungeons to explore and as the name
implies you have four characters to swap
between to mix-and-match your powers
during combat cyber dimension Neptunia
comes to western ps4s on tuesday the
10th with a PC release coming next year
speaking of virtual cyber worlds you can
also strap into your PS VR headset with
raw data the future is run by the Eaton
Corporation but a group of elite hackers
have discovered that things are not
quite as utopian as they seem
be prepared to take down your enemies
with both guns and nanotech powers raw
data left early access for the oculus
rift and HTC vive last week but it's
coming to psvr
on the 10th
I'm willing to bet that its version of
hacking will be way more believable than
any of those cop shows well isolate to
note and dump them on the other side of
the router I'm trying it's moving too
fast
all right that's enough violence for now
let's tone things down with the adorable
yo no and the celestial elephants this
adventure puzzle game focuses on the
little pachyderm and his trunk which can
be filled with air water and other
objects to solve puzzles the world is
occupied by humans zombies and robots
and you've got a bunch of towns and
dungeons to explore as you learn about
the history of the ancient elephants now
if that doesn't sound like a Nintendo
switch game I don't know what does but
it's also coming to PC via Steam on
Thursday the 12th and now we move from
the adorable to the terrifying the
Mobius corporation is still up to no
good and the evil within - but this time
it has a hold of protagonist Sebastian's
daughter thought to be long dead to
rescue her he'll have to use a
combination of skills stealth and
weapons
this time however levels are much larger
with multiple ways through and side
objectives along the way did I mention
the game is set in the world of Union
which was formed from his daughter's
brain yeah you can dive into the
disturbing on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Friday the 13th
that's pretty fitting and those are some
of the hottest games coming this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with more new
releases next Sunday